jesús rodríguez acaba de salir de
prisión y lo peor de su paso por la
cárcel fue ser una persona con vih
mientras pagó condena su vida corrió
riesgo porque no contó con la atención
médica en los tratamientos necesarios
para controlar la enfermedad si las
personas que estaban en libertad se le
hacía imposible retirar tratamiento por
la situación de trasladarse de un lugar
a otro porque no podían ir entonces
imagínense nosotros la cuarte no quería
sacar a ningún privado libertad para el
traslado al hospital en el hospital
cuando llegamos a ir no nos quisieron
recibir
como jesús más de 100.000 personas con
vih en venezuela no han podido acudir a
las consultas ni han tenido acceso a los
antirretrovirales durante la cuarentena
por kobe 19
datos recolectados por los monitores de
la sociedad civil señalan que entre
enero y octubre de 2020 la principal
causa de la muerte de más de 1000
pacientes fue la falta de tratamiento
una cifra que miembros de ongs temen
puede ser mucho más alta nosotros no
hemos conseguido que cuando vamos a la
'la a los centros públicos de salud nos
niegan la información y las actas de
defunción no reflejan la veracidad de
las muertes entonces son veladas son
disfrazadas se niegan a colocar la
palabra sida en un intento de ganar
espacios para hacer valer el derecho de
la vida de las personas con vih
mauricio gutiérrez seropositivo ha
decidido lanzar su candidatura como
diputado en las próximas elecciones de
la asamblea nacional el sistema público
de salud
nos está dejando a morir y hasta el
momento la respuesta de todos los
poderes públicos ha sido ninguna
hablan
de nosotros solamente para utilizarlos
con fines partidistas proselitistas
tenemos como personas afectadas ocupar
espacio de toma de decisiones se estima
que el desabastecimiento de los
antirretrovirales llega al 65 por ciento
desde el año 2016 el gobierno venezolano
no compra medicamentos ni los reactivos
necesarios para diagnosticar el vih en
venezuela- los organismos
internacionales son quienes se han
encargado de ayudar a este sector
vulnerable de la población que se
encuentra en una situación de
desatención y de discriminación termina
fernández france24 caracas